foreign
ER Tom Peterson is having to truck water
in so his cows have something to drink
to stay alive under normal circumstances
they would drink from a local pond but
here's the problem it's dried up and on
Peterson's soy Fields the crops might
look healthy from a distance but the
roots of the plants that should be
covered with wet mud instead have
nothing and like most Farmers here
Peterson doesn't have access to man-made
irrigation systems he relies solely on
rainfall so whatever uh whatever rain
falls that's the water you get that's
the water we get
and nothing else no and if no rain falls
that's the problem that's the problem
that's the problem we had this spring no
rain fell Nebraska is going through its
worst drought since the 1950s it's
complicating Harvest of corn and
soybeans so we kind of got what I would
call double dip flash drought so two uh
separate periods of Rapid
intensification of drought in a state
that by some measurements is the third
largest agricultural exporting state in
all of America some rain started falling
a few weeks ago stating off total crop
loss but an intense hail storm destroyed
many crops already fighting for survival
you might be wondering why it matters
that there's a drought here in Nebraska
the answer is because what happens here
in the agricultural Heartland of America
can directly affect food prices in
various parts of the world whether
you're talking about China Mexico South
America or Europe although those markets
are served by agriculture from this part
of the country and likewise without this
uh with drought going on that tends to
push up agricultural commodity prices in
his Fields Peterson opens up an ear of
corn to see the tip is missing kernels
it's a Tell-Tale sign of lack of water
and uncertainty of what's to come if
more rain doesn't fall soon at this
point nobody really knows what it's
going to be like so we'll have to it's a
wait and see in this heartland region of
America
many farmers hope to see rain to save
their livelihoods
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera Lincoln
Nebraska
we're joined out by Michael Hayes who's
from Lincoln he's a climatologist at the
University of Nebraska it's good to have
you with us on Al Jazeera we just heard
there in Gabriel's report how difficult
it is for farming as a industry at the
moment in Nebraska but is that reflected
across the region as you look at the
changing weather patterns
this has been a very challenging year
for Farmers across the midwestern United
States which is the Corn Belt of the U.S
we've had a lot of dryness some heat
um so yes I think there are a lot of
challenges that farmers are facing this
year I mean Nebraska is is one state of
the Midwest that we I say get to imagine
it being you know the the food uh basket
of the United States and Beyond uh what
happens really to weather patterns in
this area I mean what are we seeing what
are the changes that are so very
distinctive at this moment in time
yeah it's all dependent on the timing of
when these droughts happen and how they
affect agricultural production in a
region so for this region in particular
it was a very dry fall and winter last
year and that set the stage for soils to
be very dry and then those conditions
intensified this spring and kind of
peaked in the June the month of June and
so that's been very challenging for the
agricultural production which includes
wheat corn soybeans and livestock in
this region if water is scarce is it
economical or even cost effective for
Farmers to consider bringing in tankers
of water or cloud seeding are these
possible alternatives
sure I think they are things to think
about but
um I would say that there might be some
other solutions that uh Farmers could
look at and then we need to be sure that
we have the support system set up for
agricultural producers when they go
through years like this one we often
hear Farmers complaining sometimes that
the authorities and the government don't
do enough is there more that the either
the government at state level or at
Federal level could do to help farmers
because at the end of the day the
agricultural belt of Central America
feeds most of America
exactly so I think one of the things
that needs to work between government
officials and agricultural producers is
communication and making sure that uh
there is communication going between
both groups of people that they are
sharing as accurate information as
possible and that the programs are set
up for example insurance or other relief
programs that can be
administered in a timely fashion to the
agricultural producers when they need
them and then just trying to be as
accurate as possible in depicting
conditions and making sure that we have
a good understanding of the severity of
a drought that's taking place is also
very important
it's good to get your Insight Michael
Hayes joining us there from Lincoln and
from the University of Nebraska thank
you for your time sir
thank you very much